you are the guys to the hosts of the
film Independent Spirit Awards have you
seen all the movies no no not all the
movies you even didn't all the movies
ever made or then I don't know all the
I've seen like two movies all in all the
movies that are nominate you've only
seen two oh no I know I've seen a single
movie nominated I've seen a Knight's
Tale and in the movie tombstone yeah his
favorite movies are a Knight's Tale in
tombs yeah and I in college I had a
poster of Pulp Fiction okay I know what
movie was great this year
what father of the bride on TV you could
flip back and forth with ice skaters
yeah yeah so you guys haven't watched
any of that could be awkward no you get
interviewed if people ask you what did
you think of this movie if you meet the
talent and they ask you what did you
think of the film that could be on
alka-seltzer yeah you shoe Alka Singh
can you start your rave you start the
fun with them yeah what do you do I mean
what do you there's no way to view
people where you haven't seen their film
I occasionally do yeah yeah okay you
know what I do I don't lie you don't
don't lie I don't say I saw the film I
say a lot of people love this film look
for that at home when you hear when you
hear me say when you hear me say there's
a lot of talk about this movie yeah so
yeah and if I say here's a really great
scene it's because I watched that see
the truth you know that's a good scene
yeah I don't know it's a great scene I
guess you're saying here is here is the
scene yeah I don't like to say I watched
the movie and go into great detail about
how I loved it and I watched it if I
absolutely haven't seen any you could
always go hey you're certainly on the
show tonight well you two are alive good
to say thanks
you